therefore rishi sunak and liz trust
will be the candidates going forward
conservative party mps have spoken now
grassroots members will decide whether
former chancellor rishi sunak or foreign
secretary liz truss should go on to be
party leader and britain's next prime
minister
both are divisive characters both have
the experience of high office trust
promises what she calls a truly
conservative economic agenda tax cuts
and a hike in defense spending i'm the
person who can go into number 10 i can
hit the ground running and i can get
things done
sunak says he'll stabilize the economy
ease the cost of living crisis and win
the next election
the question now for our members is who
is the best person to defeat kirstama in
the labour party at the next election i
believe i'm the only candidate who can
do that
and there's a further distinction
between the two
while liz truss is seen as the candidate
most likely to continue boris johnson's
brand of populist politics rishi sunak
isn't popular in downing street where
he's seen as having betrayed johnson
earning him the distrust of party
members a poll of those very party
members who will elect the next prime
minister suggests that liz truss is far
more likely to win than rishi sunak
before the focus shifted to a very
public summer leadership campaign there
was time for parliament to say goodbye
to boris johnson at his final session at
the dispatch box in prime minister's
questions
i do know that the relationship between
a prime minister and leader of the
opposition
is never easy
and this one's proved no exception to
the rule
but i would like to take this
opportunity to wish him his wife and his
family the best for the future
johnson had this advice for his
successor number one stay close to the
americans stick up for the ukrainians
stick up for freedom and democracy
everywhere
johnson's relatively short tenure
included he said restoring the uk's
independence from europe and battling
the pandemic but then a string of
scandals brought his office into
disrepute
mr speaker i want to thank everybody
here and
hasta la vista
baby thank you
johnson exited the house of commons to
rousing applause the next prime minister
will be named on september the 5th jonah
al jazeera london